DAN HOLEVOET: Hi, everybody.
We're going to get started.
My name's Dan Holevoet, and I'm
an engineer on Google's
Developer Relations team.
And I'm going to talk to you
today about how you can launch
your app inside of Google
Apps using gadgets.
And while I'm presenting here,
we're going to use Wave as
we've been doing in some
of the other sessions.
We'll have live notes taken
inside of the Wave.
And if you have any questions
you want to ask while I'm
presenting, you can feel free to
add those inside of Google
Moderator in the Wave.
So just go to this bitly URL
that I have on the slide here,
and I'll give you a second if
you want to open that up.
And if you don't grab this URL
while it's up here, you can
actually go to my session
information on the Google I/O
website to get the URL there.
So what are going to
talk about today?
Here's a quick little
agenda for you.
First thing, why gadgets?
Why are you here?
Why do you care?
Basic motivation for developing
these gadgets--
some details on what gadgets
are; where gadgets work; some
common tasks and best practices
that'll help you out
while you're writing these
gadgets; some information on
how to distribute these
gadgets; an example
application that I wrote that
will demonstrate some of
things that I've been
showing you.
And then finally, hopefully,
I'll have convinced you all to
go out and start writing
these yourselves.
And we have some information
on how you can get started.
And then, of course, we'll
do some Q&A at the end.
So first, why gadgets?
Well, how many of you are
Google Apps users?
Hopefully I get a few hands.
Oh, nice.
So how many of you spend
a lot of your day
inside of Google Apps?
That's fairly common.
And I can imagine for a lot of
you, once you start using
Google Apps it's really
where you want to
do all of your work.
And you'll come to a point where
you actually find it
really inconvenient to go
outside of Apps to do
something and then have
to come back.
Because Google Apps is where
you do all of your work.
Your workflow is inside
of Google Apps.
And so gadgets let you take
pieces of the other
applications that you find
valuable and bring them into
Google Apps.
They then become part
of your workflow.
So you can see in this diagram
here, we have some really cool
app that does this
really critical
piece for our business.
And we can take that app, and we
can put it inside of all of
the Google Apps that we use on a
daily basis so that we don't
have to leave Google Apps,
do some piece of work,
and then come back.
We can just integrate this
little piece of functionality
inside of the Google Apps
that we're already,
every single day.
So what are gadgets?
At the simplest level, gadgets
are XML, HTML,
and JavaScript, right?
They're little embedded web
pages inside of Google Apps.
You can see a really simple
example gadget here.
This is the Hello World
of gadgets.
We have a module section, which
basically encompasses
the entire definition
of the gadget.
We have a module prep section
for declaring things like the
gadgets title, and then the
content section, which is
where we include HTML and
JavaScript that basically
describes the application.
And so in this particular case,
it's really simple.
It just says Hello World,
and that's it.
And while you've been at I/O,
I'm sure you've been hearing
about all the great things
that are coming in HTML5.
And all those things you can
do inside of gadgets, too.
So this is the smallest HTML5
gadget that you can fit into a
single slide.
So this uses the canvas tag and
draws a little blue box.
So it's not the most
entertaining or useful demo,
but this is the same HTML5 that
we're talking about and
that you've been hearing about
over the last two days.
So this is basically
what it looks like.
This is living inside
of iGoogle.
It's really straightforward.
This is the HTML5 version
of Hello World.
So in addition to all of those
things, all the stuff you get
just by using HTML5 and
JavaScript and CSS, there are
some additional gadget-specific
APIs that we
give you access to.
So the first one of those is
the dynamic-height library.
And what that lets you do is
adjust the size of the gadget
based on how much content
you have inside.
So if you have a lot of content,
you actually can
increase the height
of the gadget.
If you only want to show a
little bit of content, you can
shrink the size of the gadget
and basically take up as
little UI space as you
need inside of
the screen real estate.
The next one of these is
the Views feature.
And views allow you to have
multiple facets to your
application or your gadget.
So some common ones that you
might have seen if you've ever
developed a gadget on iGoogle,
for instance, there's the Home
and the Canvas view.
The Home view is the view that
you first see when you install
that gadget on your page.
It's shared with several other
gadgets or your newsfeeds and
things like that.
And the Canvas view allows you
to take advantage of almost
the entire page and gives you a
lot more room to work with.
And we'll see there are a couple
other types of views
that are sort of similar to
these that are available
inside of other pieces of
the Google Apps suite.
And then finally, we have to
the osapi.http classes.
And these allow you to fetch
data from remote sites and
bring that data inside
of your gadget.
And because all of these gadgets
are running inside of
their own sub-domain, you have
the normal restrictions due to
the same origin policy.
So your normal XHR requests
aren't going to work.
So we provide this class so that
you can use that instead
so that you can fetch
this remote content.
And this also gives you things
like OAuth signing so that you
have a verifiable way to
determine what container or
what piece of Google Apps
is requesting this data.
You have a unique identifier for
the user of the gadget at
that particular time.
And then we also allow you to
use the normal HTTP method so
you can do GETs, you can do
POSTs, can do PUTs, et cetera.
And then finally, we have
some helper methods.
If you're fetching XML or if
you're fetching JavaScript
objects, you get back
JavaScript objects.
So if you make a request to a
JSON endpoint somewhere, what
you get back is actually a
JavaScript object that
you can just use.
You don't have to eval it.
Heaven forbid that you
ever want to do that
in the first place.
You don't have to pass it
through your own JSON library.
You can just start using it
right when you get it back.
So where do gadgets work?
I've hinted at a couple places
already, just talking.
The ones we're going to focus
on today, I'll give you a
brief summary.
So the first of those is inside
of Google Calendar.
And so you can see here, this
is a simple "what's the next
event" gadget, running
on the right-hand
side of Google Calendar.
Google Calendar provides
you with two views.
The first one of those is the
nav view, which is the one
we're looking at here, and the
second of which is the canvas
view, which actually takes
over the frame where your
events would normally be and
allows you to use that really
large section of screen
real estate.
And then in addition to
that, there's also the
google.calendar APIs, which let
you do things like when a
user clicks on Event, you can
get the details about the
event that they've clicked on.
Or if the user switches what
set of dates that they're
looking at in their calendar
UI, you can get access to
those dates inside of your
gadget and trigger some
special behavior.
The next one is Google Sites.
And the really cool part of
having gadgets inside of Sites
is that these are really a great
way to embed HTML and
JavaScript inside of Sites--
and actually the only way to
do that at the moment--
and really brings dynamic
content to your pages.
So we have an example here.
This is a gadget embedded inside
of a quarterly report.
And we could have just
used an image here.
But this is actually going
out to a server.
It's fetching live data,
bringing it back inside of the
gadget, and giving us a live
chart based off of data that's
actually current.
So this isn't frozen in time.
It's live based off of what's
happening in our server.
And Sites gives you two views
similar to these other
containers.
We have the profile view,
which is what
you're seeing here.
And then there's also a
configuration view, which I'll
talk a little bit about later,
which you can use to actually
set up these gadgets when you
add them to your Sites pages.
And then finally, we're going
to talk about Gmail.
So this gadget we're
showing here is the
Google Calendar gadget.
You've probably seen this inside
of Gmail, and you may
have said, well, oh, I didn't
realize that was a gadget.
So this is actually a gadget.
This is a gadget built by
Google using the same
technology that we're going
to talk about during this
presentation that we've
used to add a really
cool feature to Gmail.
And so this is the left nav that
we're looking at here and
the nav view.
And there's also a canvas view
which takes over the mail pane
where you have your inbox or
your list of threads or the
thread that you're currently
looking at.
So you have a really big section
of real estate to work
with inside of Gmail.
And then another place to embed
gadgets inside of Gmail,
which we actually just announced
on Tuesday, is Gmail
contextual gadgets.
And unfortunately, I can't do
contextual gadgets justice
talking about them just in
this one presentation.
So I'm actually giving another
session on them today at 4:45.
So we'll talk a little
bit about them here.
And hopefully, you'll be really
interested in them and
come to the other session
on those later.
So contextual gadgets basically
match on the fields
of an email message, so who
the message is to, who the
message is from, a specific
pattern that you might see
inside of the email body, a link
or an image or something
like that, and then, based off
of those matches, trigger a
gadget which then has access
to that particular context.
So in this case here, we're
looking at the Google Docs
contextual gadget.
And so John Doe has sent me a
link to an important document.
And I could click on that link,
and I could open up
Google Docs, read the document,
come back to my
Gmail, and send off a response
to this particular message.
Or I could, actually using the
contextual gadget, click on
the Show Preview option and
see the contents of the
document right below
the email.
And then I can read the email,
and I can reply to John
without ever having
to leave my inbox.
So this is a really
powerful feature.
I've shown you a little bit
about where you can use each
of these gadgets.
And so you're probably saying,
OK, well, I have the basic
idea of where they can go.
But here are some things that
I'm interested in doing.
And when I write these gadgets,
how do I do things
like fetch data?
So this is a really
common practice.
There's basically four
steps to this.
It's actually really simple.
The steps are mostly
behind the scenes.
So using the aforementioned
osapi.http class, we would
write this little snippet
of code here.
You can see we're using
the GET method.
You could also use a POST
or a PUT, et cetera.
You can actually specify a
payload if you're interested.
We're sending a request to
example.com for some JSON.
And this is an asynchronous
request.
We're not going to block
the browser.
So we need to specify
a callback method.
And we're going to
use that here.
So when we call execute, we're
going to pass in the method
handleResponse.
So whenever this data comes back
from the container site,
that we'll call handleResponse,
pass in the
JavaScript object that we're
given, and then the gadget can
do something useful with it.
So once we send off this
JavaScript request, that's
going to go to the container
website.
In this case, it's my depiction
of Google Sites.
And then that's going to pass it
off to whatever remote site
we're requesting
the data from.
So it could be App Engine.
It could be the server that
you've already built.
It could be a public or a
third-party website that has
public data.
Really, any publicly available
site on the internet or even
using something like secure
data connector you could
request data that's private
to your own domain.
So that site will receive a
request, sends back some data
which will go to
the container.
And then the container
will proxy that data
back into the gadget.
It's relatively straightforward.
You can just start
using the data.
You can render it inside of the
gadget, do all sorts of
useful things.
So the next thing that we'll
talk about is authentication.
And this actually works
relatively similarly to how
you would fetch data.
So when we make one of these
requests to a remote site, we
can actually request that the
container append identifying
information to that particular
request about the user and
about what site it's
coming from.
And we do that by adding
this line here.
So we have "authz, signed."
And what that does is when the
request gets to the container,
the container will append
a unique user ID
for the current user.
And we also call that
the OpenSocial ID.
And it will cryptographically
sign this request.
So basically it takes
all of the
parameters and the requests.
If you pass in a payload, if
you're using a PUT or a POST,
basically mash all those
parameters together, assign
them with a secret key that
only you as the gadget
developer and Google have access
to, and then create a
hash and append that to
the end of the request
inside of the URL.
So then when the recipient site
gets that message, you
can then again repeat basically
the same process.
You can push together all the
parameters that were sent in
the request using your copy
of that secret key.
Recreate the hash.
Verify that it's the same.
And then you know that the
request has come from this
particular container that it's
identified itself as.
And so inside of that request
you have access to
this unique user ID.
And if you're comfortable just
using that, you have this
verifiable way to identify a
specific user of your gadget.
And then the remainder of
the steps are the same.
The server sends back some data
to the container, and the
container passes that data
back to the gadget.
You might be saying to yourself,
well, having that
idea's cool, but I have a
database, and the database has
lots of information
about this user.
Maybe they already have an
account on my site, and I'd
like to tie that to this
OpenSocial ID.
Or in the context of using the
Google Apps Marketplace, I
have this marketplace
application, and
that's using OpenID.
How would I take this OpenSocial
ID and tie that to
the OpenID?
This is a little
bit confusing.
I'll walk through it
right now briefly.
If anyone has any questions on
this, please feel free to ask
at the end.
So the first thing that we do
here is we start out sending
that request to the
remote site.
So we have the "authz signed."
This is going to give us that
unique OpenSocial ID in the
request to the server.
And so this is some App Engine
Python-like pseudocode that
you couldn't precisely use
inside of your app.
But this will give you a pretty
good idea of what type
of thing we're doing here.
And so we get this request.
We have the OpenSocial ID
inside of our database.
And so we're going to look for
any user that has that
OpenSocial ID associated with
their user objects.
And we'll do a little query
for that here, pulling the
value out of the URL.
If we happen to not find the
user, which will be the first
time the gadget loads, we can
create a temporary user inside
of our database, pass in that
OpenSocial ID again.
And then we're going to save
along with that a random
value, basically a one-time-use
token.
This could be a session token,
any kind of value that you
want, as long as you're only
going to use it a single time.
And you can uniquely associate
that with this particular row
in the database that
we're saving here.
And then we'll pass that data,
that session token back to the
gadget along with basically
a status.
We didn't find the user.
You're going to need to
do a second step of
authentication here.
And this will basically indicate
to the gadget to
initiate that flow.
And then in the other case where
we already have this
user stored, you don't
have to do anything.
You can tell the gadget
basically they're
authenticated.
You could also pass back
information about that user,
whatever data you have stored
inside of your application
that you want to use inside
of the gadget.
Going back to the flow,
we need to do more
authentication.
So in this particular case,
we're going to be focusing on
applications using OpenID.
So we're going to open
up this OpenID URL.
This could be a link to your
server, basically, where you
go through the OpenID
flow process.
And you'd append to that URL
that unique session token that
you passed back from
your server.
So you open this up inside
of a window.
The user will be prompted to
grant access to your site and
log in with their OpenID
credentials, which in this
case would be through
Google Apps.
That'll redirect itself
a couple times.
And then finally, it'll
end up on your site.
And so you'll have details about
the user from OpenID.
And because you've also passed
in the SessionToken, you'll
have details about the
user's OpenSocial ID.
And at that point, you can save
those in your database.
And you know basically who the
user is through OpenID.
You know who they are through
the gadget, because you have
the two correlated.
And then you've also potentially
know more
information that you've saved
in the database because
they've logged in through
OpenID before.
And at this point, you can close
the pop-up window with
some simple JavaScript.
And then inside of the gadget,
which can basically check on
the status of that pop-up window
being the window that
created it, you can do sort
of a sanity check.
Send this back to your site.
Make sure that the user is
actually in the database.
And hopefully, you send
back the signal that
everything is great.
If it's not, maybe the user
closed the pop-up window
before they actually
authenticated.
You can put up a little warning
message basically
saying, oh, we really need you
to log in and go through that
process one more time.
So at this point, the
user has logged in.
You know who they are
on your database.
You know what their OpenSocial
ID is in the database.
And every time they load the
gadget from this point on, you
can just send that one single
request, look up that
OpenSocial ID, and
you're done.
So the next thing, writing
safe gadgets.
So the most important thing
here is stick to the
HTML and CSS specs.
The number one reason to do
this, when you go outside of
the spec you're just going to
create compatibility problems
for yourself.
Every browser is trying to
follow the HTML as CSS specs
as closely as possible.
Some of them do it a little
bit better than others.
But they're all on the road
to following these specs.
And if you follow these you're
going to have the best time in
the future maintaining
compatibility.
You should also use safe
DOM operations.
Doing things like document.write
aren't going to
help your application at all.
And in the worst case, they're
going to open you up to things
like prostate scripting.
On the same token, use
supported event
handlers and timers.
All of these things are
basically going to ensure
compatibility, reduce the scope
of possible attacks
against your gadgets.
And then in order to help you
on this goal, we actually
recommend the use of the
following frameworks, Google
Web Toolkit, OpenSocial
Templates, and then JQuery.
So here are some examples of
the good, the bad, and the
ugly of writing safe gadgets.
The first two examples are good
ways to append the text
Hello World to your gadget.
The second one is something
you definitely
don't want to do.
And then finally, this is a
slightly different class of
security exploit.
Don't trust things like where
you're going to redirect the
window to to the results
of a potentially
unsanitized user input.
So you wouldn't want to call an
API method that gets a URL
and then just trust the user
or some other data that's
inside of your system that's
never been sanitized.
So don't do this.
This is very bad.
So you have this gadget.
It's safe, uses HTML
and CSS specs.
It requests data from third
parties and can
authenticate the user.
How do you distribute this?
So inside of Gmail and Calendar,
the contextual
gadgets that I mentioned
before-- and we'll talk a
little bit about them in my
other session-- those are
distributed through the Google
Apps Marketplace.
Sidebar gadgets inside of
Gmail and Calendar are
currently a labs feature.
So you would turn on that Add
Gadget by URL lab inside of
the Gmail and Calendar UI.
And then you just add the link
to the gadget inside of that
UI, and it appears inside
of the navigation.
And then Calendar gadgets,
actually there's a little
shortcut for this.
If you want to paste your gadget
XML URL at the end of
this, you can actually send
this link to someone.
And when they visit it, they'll
get a little message
saying, you're attempting to add
this particular gadget to
your page, and basically ask
for permission to do so.
And then inside of Sites,
Sites actually shares a
directory with iGoogle
for gadgets.
And so if you submit your gadget
to iGoogle, it should
show up in the Google Sites
directory as well.
And there's also the Add by
URL feature there, too.
So if you want to add any custom
URL, it doesn't have to
be listed in the iGoogle
directory in
order to show up here.
And then finally, since a lot
of these gadgets hopefully
that you're interested in
writing will be distributed
along with other pieces that
are in the Google Apps
Marketplace, if you want to do
things like add a link inside
of Google's universal navigation
or support OpenID
whitelisting so that that
authentication step I was
talking a little bit about
before, you can actually skip
the user having to do an
approval process for that.
Or if you want to write Gmail
contextual gadgets, you should
list in the marketplace.
And again, this is another topic
that there's just so
much to mention that
I couldn't do
it all in this session.
So thankfully we've had a number
of other sessions in
the last two days about writing
for the marketplace.
And I'd encourage all of
you to check those out.
We also have documentation on
code.google.com about writing
marketplace apps.
I've talked a little--
or a lot-- about these different
API calls, where
these things work.
And you haven't seen
an example.
So let's see an example
application that I wrote.
This is called Tick Track, and
it's a ticket tracking system.
It allows you to basically
create a ticket queue and
assign owners and statuses to
email messages that come in,
which are basically the tickets
in this system.
And each of the gadgets that
live inside of Google Apps
give you specific dashboard
views and allow you to take
actions based off of these
tickets that have come in.
So let's just jump
to the demo.
So here's the application, just
as it lives by itself.
So on the left, we have
a list of agents.
Now, here's myself.
If I click on myself I can
see all the tickets
that I've been assigned.
Here they all are here.
If I click on one of these, we
can see who the email message
came from, that it's
assigned to me.
I could do actions
like unassign it
or take it, et cetera.
Pretty straightforward.
But this right now lives
outside of Google Apps.
So if I want to use this, I have
to jump over to this app,
look at what's in my queue,
possibly assign it to someone,
go inside of Gmail, take
some action, et cetera.
And it's a slightly
awkward workflow.
So how can we make
this better?
Let me jump back to
the slides here.
Sorry about that.
So here's a quick architecture
diagram of what this app's
going to do.
So we have this gadget that
lives inside of one of these
Google Apps.
We're sending the OpenSocial
ID to the App Engine app,
which is the back end here.
And to handle the mailing list
functionality and the ticket
tracking functionality, we're
actually using Google Groups.
And so that's sending all of
the email messages to these
particular groups into
App Engine using the
incoming email API.
And then finally, data about
the particular thread that
we're looking at or the
particular agent that's
working on these tickets gets
sent back to the gadgets so
that we can display that
inside of Google Apps.
So first let's look at
the gadget living
inside of Google Calendar.
So here we are.
Here's today.
On the right side we have a
list of threads that I've
worked on in the last week.
When my manager comes to me and
says, hey, Dan, what have
you been doing?
Yeah, the I/O stuff, OK, I don't
really care about that.
But what else have
you been doing?
I can go to this gadget and I
can say, well, look, here are
the things I did in
the last week.
I have these four threads.
I can see some basic details
about them, what they're
called, and get a total
of how many of these
things I've worked on.
Actually, if I flip
back in time--
let me flip forward in
time for a second
and reload this page.
All right.
If I flip back in time to look
at the previous week, I'm
actually looking at the
particular week that the
user's inspecting and passing
that into the gadget.
So in this case the gadget then
says, oh, well, let's
look at the date range that the
user's looking at and pull
out the threads that
he was working on
that particular week.
So you can see last week I had
another simple question I was
working on.
And it was only one
thread that week.
So I guess I was sort
of slacking off.
The week before that we
have another two.
And as I flip through these,
each one of those date ranges
gets passed to the gadget and
then loads the tickets from
that particular week.
So how are we doing that?
We're doing that through the
Google Calendar subscribe to
dates method.
And this is actually
really simple.
Basically you just pass in a
function that accepts one
value, which is the dates
that we're looking at.
And that's the date range.
So we have two of those.
The first one of those
is the start time.
And we can convert that into
basically a time stamp that
we're looking at here.
We do that for both of these and
then send that off to App
Engine, along with
my OpenSocial ID.
And because that's already
correlated with my user agent
inside of the database, it can
send back all the tickets that
I worked on in that
particular week.
So the next one that
we'll look at here
is a gadget in Sites.
And this is actually a single
gadget that we're looking at
here, but it has four different
views that we've
implemented.
And I'll tell you a little bit
about how we're doing that in
just a second.
Network's just a little
bit slow.
OK.
So you can see here, on the top
left, we have the tickets
that are owned by particular
people.
So you can see, I guess
I/O's been taking
up a lot of my time.
There's a lot of tickets in this
queue that haven't been
assigned to anyone.
I've only done nine
of these here.
That's not so good.
My manager's going
to be unhappy.
And if we look at the other
details here, you can see the
total number of tickets that's
come in, how many of those
were resolved, the total number
of tickets per day.
We can click on all
these things.
And all these charts are done
by the Google Visualizations
API, which I encourage all
of you to check out.
It's really awesome, and these
are super easy to create.
And then we have this
big number.
If we had to have one number
about how we're doing, what's
the average resolution time
on all these tickets?
So we can see 79.52 hours.
That's not very good.
My manager's probably going to
yell at me about that one.
So I have some work to
do when I get back.
We'll see how that goes.
But anyway, these are
all one particular
gadget that we've installed.
And actually, if I edit the page
here, when I click on one
of these gadgets, I can pull
up the properties.
So this is similar to what you'd
see when you actually
install one of these gadgets
on your page.
We have details about how wide
is the gadget, how tall is the
gadget, do we want to
give it a name.
And this box, this piece at the
top here is configuration
that we've added inside
of the gadget.
So when I add this gadget I can
pick what kinds of details
I'm interested in displaying.
So this is a really simple
example of this.
I just want to have four
different views.
But we could also do things
like, well, what agent do we
want to look at?
Or is there a particular date
range that we're interested in
looking at instead of
just the last 30
days, like I'm showing?
We can have different
preferences for
all of these things.
There's some really
complicated logic
we wanted to add.
We could add that here.
And actually, if we wanted
to rewrite this entire
configuration page, we could
do that using the
configuration view.
So when a person adds this
gadget, instead of seeing all
the site's configuration options
we can actually create
our own configuration options.
So the possibilities for
configuring these gadgets is
actually quite limitless.
And so you can see the gadget
here, so this top left one, I
picked the ownership option.
And that's what triggers
the display on
this particular chart.
And inside of the API, we can
actually see how we're
describing this behavior.
So we're using the
UserPref API.
And so this is the code, the
actual code that we're using
to display this particular
choice.
So we're declaring an enum here,
the values 0 through 3.
And with each one of those,
we're giving basically the
name that shows up
in the UI and
associating that with a value.
And then when the gadget loads
we request that UserPref
that's been saved.
It's basically an integer
display type.
And then we have a really simple
switch statement that
we iterate through and pull up
the value and then trigger the
right UI behavior based off of
the option that was set.
And then finally let's look at
the gadget inside of Gmail.
And what this will give us is
a list of tickets that are
owned by the current user.
And we'll just wait for
Gmail to refresh
itself here really quickly.
And so on the left-hand side
here, you can see I have two
tickets that are currently
assigned to me.
One of these is a
simple question.
The second one is a
tricky question.
And I've actually gone through
my inbox and triaged these
here and added them to this
particular label.
But let's say that I
hadn't done that.
Let's say that I was just in my
inbox right now, and I want
to jump to one of these.
So let's click on that
little arrow there.
We're going to do a little
quick search.
And then we pulled up the
particular email that I'm
interested in working on.
That's a simple question.
That sounds fine.
We'll click on this here.
And we can work on that one.
So I'll accept this one.
And that's done.
I'll work on that later.
Let's look at this
other one here.
And we can actually look at--
the question shows up inside
of the subject line here.
That's a tricky question,
does P equal NP?
Well, that sounds
kind of hard.
So I'm actually not going
to work on that.
I'm going to unassign it, pass
it to my colleague, and just
forget that that
one's in there.
So we'll come back to
that one later.
So you can see, I've basically
done the entire triaging
process of all these incoming
tickets that are assigned to
me just from inside
of my inbox.
I didn't have to jump
over to another app.
I can do all of that
here without
interrupting my workflow.
And actually, one more thing
that I'll show you here just
as another little teaser for
contextual gadgets, I can
actually jump into
one of these.
And you notice this is being
triggered on the particular
mailing list here.
So this is my mail queue.
And so I have a contextual
gadget installed that will
actually look for messages
sent to that alias.
And when those messages come in,
if I happen to open them
inside of my inbox it actually
triggers this particular
gadget to show up
at the bottom.
So I can see here that
this is unassigned.
And actually, why don't I
assign that to one of my
colleagues, too?
So now it's actually
taken care of.
And if I go back to the search
results, I can actually remove
this for my queue.
And it's been completely
triaged.
So I've actually gone in,
assigned an owner inside of
the inbox, removed a label, and
now it wouldn't even show
up inside of my followup without
ever having to leave
my inbox at all.
And on this particular one,
I can actually shoot
off a reply as well.
So I'll say, well, "what is the
airspeed velocity of an
unladen swallow?" I can answer
this with a question.
"African or European?"
Send that off.
And I can mark it as resolved,
and I'm done.
So I haven't had to
leave my inbox.
And I've actually entered the
ticket, gone through the
entire workflow of working on
one of these tickets that's
come into my inbox without ever
having to leave, without
ever having to go to one
of these other apps.
So if you're interested on how
I wrote that app, again I'd
encourage you to come
to the talk later.
Finally, let's talk about the
application manifest.
So this is based on the context
of being part of a
Google Apps Marketplace
application.
So for doing things like
adding a link into the
universal navigation or
whitelisting for OpenID, this
is basically the small set of
lines that you need to add to
one of those manifests
in order to have
those features work.
And then gadgets are not
currently installable via the
marketplace, except for
contextual gadgets.
But we're hoping
on having those
extensions available soon.
So you'd have a couple more
lines here if you want to add
a sidebar gadget in Gmail or a
sidebar gadget in Calendar or
a gadget in Sites.
So hopefully I've convinced you
all to get started writing
these gadgets for yourself.
And so we have developer
documentation on all these
different types of gadgets--
Gmail gadgets, both contextual
and Sidebar, Calendar gadgets,
Sites gadgets, and some
documentation on the
marketplace.
And we have a developer forum
for these gadgets as well.
So if you have any questions on
writing gadgets for Google
apps, I'd encourage
you to go here.
I'll give you a second if you
want to copy that down.
There's also links to that from
each of these developer
sites, too.
It's fairly easy to find.
And like I said, other talks,
Contextual Gadgets today in
this room at 4:45.
And then I'd encourage all of
you to look at the other
enterprise talks that are
available when they're posted
on the Google I/O if you weren't
fortunate enough to
see them already.
And so now I think it's
time for questions.
I'll switch over to
the Wave here.
I'll give you all a second if
you want to open this up, too.
And have the Firefox.
All right, excellent.
So we have some questions
already.
And if anyone else has live
questions you can feel free to
come up to one of the mics.
And I'll hopefully answer
whatever burning
questions you have.
We'll start with one of the
Moderator questions, though.
So "we have Google Sites for our
corporate domain, so all
of our users have already
logged in.
Is there any other way to pass
the username to a gadget so we
can give them customized
content?"
Yes, OK, excellent.
So hopefully I've partially
answered
this particular question.
So this is a type of single
sign-on that you'd like to do
inside of a gadget.
And the easiest way to do
that is with OpenID.
And you can have OpenID turned
on for any Google Apps domain.
And so it's basically the
process that I outlined.
So you would load the gadget.
You'd have it send a request for
the OpenSocial ID to your
server that you've configured.
You'd save that ID in whatever
user's table you have.
And if you can then associate
that with your data, you're
good to go.
If not, walk through
the OpenID flow.
And then pass that basically
back into your database.
So you have the user signed
in once using OpenID.
If they're already logged into
Google Sites, they won't need
to log in again.
And more importantly, if
you've installed this
application through the Google
Apps Marketplace, there's
whitelisting.
So you won't even need to
walk through the flow.
The pop-up window will open,
do a couple automatic
redirections, and then
you're done.
So yes, this is very possible.
And hopefully my explanation of
this has been sufficient.
If not, feel free to come up to
me after, if you're here.
I'll take a live question.
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering
about the
monetization of this.
In the gadget API terms of
service, it says that you
can't sell a gadget.
DAN HOLEVOET: So is
this the generic
gadgets terms of service?
AUDIENCE: I believe so.
DAN HOLEVOET: I'd have to look
into the particular thing that
it's showing there.
So right now because these
aren't part of the Google Apps
Marketplace, it could
be out of date.
I'm sure it could stand
to be updated for
this particular context.
AUDIENCE: It's just--
we're very interested
in pursuing this.
But as you can imagine, if you
can't get paid for it, it's--
DAN HOLEVOET: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So how does one follow
up on that?
DAN HOLEVOET: I'll give you
my email address after.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That'd be great.
And then the other thing is
just about stripping the
Google identifications,
all of that off.
Apparently, you can't do that
either under the terms of
service, under the terms of the
ad Google button, and all
that kind of stuff.
DAN HOLEVOET: So that's mostly
in the context of syndicated
gadgets and not so much a gadget
that's living inside of
Sites or Gmail.
AUDIENCE: But there's
no distinction in
the terms of service.
DAN HOLEVOET: Right.
So like I said, they could
probably stand to be updated
for the marketplace and
all of that context.
So I'll make sure that we get
a lawyer to look at it.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks a lot.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have one single question.
Is it possible to parse the
content of an email and to use
it within a gadget?
DAN HOLEVOET: I guess the
question is related to
contextual gadgets?
AUDIENCE: Right.
DAN HOLEVOET: My talk will
expand a little bit on that.
It is sort of possible.
It really depends.
The contextual gadget will
basically request access to
particular parts of the email.
And so one of those parts would
be the message body.
And so assuming that the domain
administrator has
approved access for your
particular gadget to look at
that part of the email,
you then could do
some parsing of it.
Generally we wouldn't want
these gadgets to match on
every single email message.
So you'd be matching on some
other piece of content before
looking at the email body.
But yes, it is possible
if the domain
administrator approves it.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAN HOLEVOET: Yep.
Live question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You've mentioned a lot
about contextual gadgets
and the domain administrators
and marketplace and whatnot.
Are there any plans to make
contextual gadgets available
to regular Gmail accounts?
DAN HOLEVOET: We're thinking
about ways that we could do
that right now, but we don't
have anything in
particular to announce.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAN HOLEVOET: We'll do the rest
of the questions here.
"Will third-party gadgets ever
be able to open docked
overlays in Google Apps like
the gTalk chat windows in
Gmail?"
That's an excellent question.
Unfortunately, I don't know
the answer to that.
So I'm going to have to
punt on that one.
Is the person who asked that
here, by any chance?
Yes.
OK.
Follow up with me after,
and I'll give
you my email address.
"When will Apps Marketplace apps
to be able to deployed
Gmail sidebar gadgets?"
So we don't have the exact
answer to this one right now.
We really want to do this.
And I can say that
it's coming.
But I don't know exactly when.
So it's definitely something
that people are interested in.
We definitely want to do it.
There's some particular UI
issues that we're looking at.
So if you happen to have, let's
say, 10 sidebar gadgets
installed, those are all going
to run down the left side.
We want to make sure that's a
good user experience before we
turn this on for everyone.
So that's one of the
things that we're
still thinking about.
And the final question-- "How
does the gadget API compared
to iWidget, and are both
the open standard?"
I'm not that familiar
with iWidget.
I looked into it a little bit
before the talk, because I saw
this question was in here.
At some level, I think they're
fairly similar.
They're both basically HTML and
JavaScript living inside
of another app.
So in that particular sense,
they're the same.
I don't know about iWidget's
open source, whether that's
been open sourced or not.
All the gadgets that I talked
about today are based on the
OpenSocial spec, which
is an open standard.
The standard implementation of
this, the reference container,
I guess, is Apache Shindig.
And that's an Apache project,
which is also open sourced.
So you can feel free to
look at this spec.
And all the code for running
one of these
gadgets, that's all open.
So as far this is concerned,
this gadget
API is an open standard.
I don't know if it's
the open standard.
But it is certainly
an open standard.
Any other questions?
OK.
Well thank you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]